uh what happened was because now we are  going to the finish line here so he  played h4 which i think he did by the  way to create a square for the king on  h3 before he did the penetration  so he he did this against the rook c2  counter punches and now it's just uh  oh that's cruelty  that is actually playing on the same  motif that i demonstrated in the mishra  game and that is that after rook takes a  look here here we have got the discover  check hitting the king and the queen and  if the queen blocks the check then it  becomes spinned to the king and thus  not defending the f8 rock anymore this  is total carnage and actually just to  add insult to injury after this rook h8  is the most stylish  win for white when king takes pins the  queen for the second time allowing a new  queen to enter the fray